what about
accepting one of the harder things we
talked a little bit about immortality
what about accepting that life ends
so do you monoliths think about your own
mortality
how we talked about accepting that
there's ups and downs to life
what about the ultimate down which is
the finality of it do you think about
that
do you fear it you also asked me
if i'm afraid of getting older
yes and that's on the path to mortality
so let me talk about that
first step and then the last step the
last
so getting older what does that mean
when i was
18 when i was 20 my brain i felt
was at my maximum i was like nothing is
impossible i can solve
anything i could take any math puzzle
any logic puzzle any programming puzzle
and to solve it in milliseconds
i just saw the answer through problems i
was like feeling invincible
i would show up at lecture with my
newspaper
lift up my head every now and then point
to errors just
brat complete brat i would raise my hand
and correct my professors from the whole
classroom
total brand i have some of those in my
class now and it's awesome it's like
very
huge i used to be you teaching you
humility yeah
so um so so so i felt invincible and i
was like
this is it this is awesome i'm living
the life 10 years later
my brain didn't work the same way
i wasn't as good at the tiny little
puzzles
but it worked in different ways and
right now
20 years later it works in yet different
ways
and oh gosh i love the journey
can you maybe give some hints
of the interesting different ways that
your brain works
as it aged yeah i went from the phase
of sheer speed and
hardcore quantitative thinking to sort
of
stepping back being able to sort of make
more connections
being able to sort of say yeah but let's
use that thing sort of
a huge new creativity being unleashed
basically when you're young you're sort
of thinking about that one problem you
can sort of reconfigure all the
variables combinatorially in your head
and just
wipe it all out when you're you know
just a little older
you start getting more creative you
start bringing in things from different
fields and different
contexts and sort of stepping outside
the box basically it's like being in the
right race and saying
there's a ceiling why are we trying to
get through that so it's sort of
look you know thinking outside the box
and then at 40
what i'm going through now is this whole
sort of embracing the path of life
and when i say life has started already
it's not a test anymore
this is basically embracing the finality
embracing that the journey is what it's
at
so what i like to say is live every day
as if it's your last one
and make plans as if you'll never die
i always have the long term that i'm
you know sort of planning out for that
will eventually become the short term
and i always have the sort of short term
and i think this ability to sort of look
at life in the back
in the past and look at life in the
future jointly
and sort of embrace the continuity both
of life in the universe and on our
planet
as well as life as a human being from
the beginning to the end
just as a path as a journey and just
embracing every aspect of that
i mean i was talking about parenthood
the other day and how amazingly
fulfilling
it is to sort of relive childhood
through the eyes of my kid but with the
perspective
of a parent so the the
the sheer you know um
arrogance of youth yeah watching this in
my kid
i can see myself when i was 18
correcting my professor i felt so proud
yeah little did i know that my professor
was working on so much more interesting
things than the three little things he
was putting on the board that day
and i was like i'm invincible but in
fact no just a little brat
and basically right now i i sort of can
see
the the the sort of journey with a
little more humility
i can sort of look at my own students
with their
unbelievable abilities being able to do
things that i'm no longer able to do
better than i probably was ever able to
do but yet
being able to guide them and shape their
thinking
and blow their minds with new ideas in
new directions
through my perspective and i know when
something is solvable because i've been
there
but i'm not going to even bother it's
not that i can't do it
i'm sure i could if i tried i just i'm
not interested in that anymore
so what i'm embracing this journey of
aging
is how my brain is changing and how
i'm constantly trying to figure out the
niches the evolutionary niches that i'm
best adapted for
for the tasks that i'm best at
while hiring and recruiting
both assistants and research scientists
and students and postdocs and you know
that will be the best of those tasks so
but
someone still has to see the big picture
and i love being in that role
so you're at the at the time scale of a
human lifespan you're doing the same
thing that the worm
did at the evolutionary time scale of uh
growing arms of
the specialization the carp
compartmentalization
right he talks about i mean it's
fascinating to think of what uh
80 year old menolas would look back at
the
at the man that's sitting here today and
and
and laugh at the ceiling at the
arrogance finally figured out something
i was like no little thing you didn't
have you didn't figure out anything
you